So now let's dive into the
best practices for developing
Shiny apps.
And in my talk
I'm going to go over
three areas, which is organizing
your Shiny app code, organizing
your development environment,
and organizing your testing.
Since we have a limited
amount of time,
this will be a high
level overview talk.
And I'm going to introduce
concepts and tools
you should be using
and tell you why.
So if you are not
familiar with them,
you can explore them in
more details after the talk.
So how should you organize
the code inside your Shiny app?
Well, first answer is
use Shiny modules.
Shiny modules let you
decompose your application
so you can follow the Don't Repeat
Yourself coding principle.
They offer encapsulation,
modularity, reusability,
and allow you to test
the whole components.
They allow you to organize your
app in the server and the UI
part, which in
essence means that you
can define your own pair
of server and UI logic
and use it inside your app or
embedded in another module.
And so secondly, you can
also organize your code
using R6 classes.
and an R6 class
is a modern, fast, and simple
implementation of
object oriented
programming in R.
You can look at it as a more
organized Shiny module,
and R6 classes
introduces a clear system
of getting the current state of
the piece of the functionality,
the operations that
can be performed
with it, the auxiliary functions, and
the initial state of the object
that can depend on the
particular user rights, which
might be actually super useful.
So how do you organize
your code using R6 classes?
So you can keep each
class in a separate script
with a name similar
to the class name,
you can store the scripts
in the folder separate
from the other code, and
you can input the code
using a package or as in
the example,
using a use function
from the module.
Second, well, and then you
can initialize the class
with a new method,
which is ultimately
available for all the classes,
and that's just an object.
And the first option is to
use modules from wahani.
And I would like to avoid some
confusion with Shiny modules.
So the modules
I'm going to talk about right now is
something completely different
from Shiny modules.
And so the modules are
the organizational unit
for the source code and they can
contain Shiny modules or R6
classes or just functions
you define.
And the cool thing about them
is that they enforce rigor
when defining the dependencies.
It means that you have
to explicitly declare
which functions or
packages your code is using
and you have to import them.
And you also have a full
control of the things that
are available outside
the module because you
have to export them
using the export function
as shown here in the example.
And additionally, they
have a local search
and they can be used as
subunit within the package
or in scripts.
So to put it all
together, Shiny modules
R6 classes, and modules.
So Shiny modules,
they let you
reuse UI and the server parts of
the components. R6 classes,
they let you build objects that
have a single responsibility
and implement given
logic, and the webhani modules,
they have selected
dependencies and let
you organize files that could
be Shiny modules and R6
classes as a separate unit.
So OK, we covered
organizing the code,
so now
let's talk about the
development environment
and how you can organize it.
So continuous integration.
To ensure quality, automate
checks. You can run Lint and test
automatically for every pushed change.
And especially for
tests, you probably
will forget them every time.
So just automate it.
So you don't
have to think about it.
And additionally,
you can automatically
add a pull request
template that can contain
a checklist for a pull request
creator and for the reviewer
to every pull request, you can push,
you can block pushing directly
to master and block
pull requests,
merging pull requests if the test fails.
So here are some popular
continuous integration options,
Bitbucket CircleCI, Travis,
Jenkins and GitHub actions,
so I'm sure you will
find something that
will fit your technology stack.
And remember, you don't have to
start from scratch every time.
And you
can use a product
template for it.
So at Appsilon, we have
an internal product
out there with a Shiny
boiler plate template.
And we use it to initialize
the repository structure
if we start a new project. And
it contains a simple Shiny app
with modules and
Shiny modules set up.
It's also has a simple, unique test.
And the CI with Lint and
automatic unit tests.
OK, so how actually your
development environment
should look like.
So let's start
from the other way.
So what happens if you
don't take care of it?
So your development environment is
a crucial part of working in R.
And it's not only
Shiny-specific,
so otherwise, if you
don't take care of it,
you can end up
with the same code,
giving different results
on different machines.
Other projects can be affected
as in the global environment
that can change and
crush unrelated projects.
You can imagine the deployment
is long and difficult.
Establishing infrastructure
is challenging
if it's not being tracked.
And last but not least,
the team will waste time
setting up a new environment
rather than jumping straight
to work.
So this might not be a problem
when you're starting a project,
but imagine that you have
to urgently add another team
member in the middle of one.
So to solve all those problems,
we recommend following a setup.
So you can do a development
in RStudio running inside
a Docker container, which is fixed
and dedicated to your project.
And you can leverage
Docker and the renv package
to control the underlying
system dependencies and
R packages.
Docker and renv together
make team collaboration easy.
So all the changes to the Docker
file and renv reports
of the packages
used in the project
are committed to the DockerHub repository
and to the code repository.
For example, GitHub is what our
team is using.
On the other hand, the
previous solution still
requires some level
of devops skills and what
we observe with our clients,
especially the enterprise ones,
they choose to work with
RStudio Server Pro, that
allows their data science
team to purely focus
on delivering value,
using their core
competencies in a highly secure
and flexible environment.
Obviously, he still
wants to use renv
to control the
dependencies and keep them
separate for every project
so different team members
can easily collaborate.
So the last bit.
I'm going to talk about is testing.
And my message.
And my message
here is just do it.
The only question is, what
tests and in what proportion
should you be writing?
And we will use the testing
pyramid to answer that.
So you should aim to have
the most unique tests
and data validation. The next
test components, a.k.a.
testing Shiny modules, does the
whole scenario with end
to end testing,
perform load tests,
and finally test usability
with user interest in mind.
Now let's quickly talk about
the tools you have available.
Sor for unit tests,
I'm sure you all
know the testthat package, so
just use it, but please set up
your architecture early and
don't tell yourself an excuse
to do it later,
because that probably
won't happen because your Shiny
application would be awesome
and your clients or
your business partners
would like to move
on to something else.
So start each project
with testing architecture.
You already know that you
have a project template to set
up at the beginning.
You also know that you can
use continuous integration
to trigger the
test automatically
so you don't have
to do it manually.
And please write at least some
tests for each piece of code
and it would be easier to
extend them later. And obviously,
keep your standards high,
so do not accept pull requests that
don't include tests or actually
break them.
And so now it's the part about data
validation, and
this is the logic.
This is the
functionality that you
should be doing on the same
level as the unique tests.
So as we all know
from our experience,
data can be very messy.
And actually kind
of users report
that this is their
biggest pain is the data.
So I want to introduce you
to a data validation package, which
is a tool for creating reports
based on the ROpenSci assetr's
validation results, and
it allows you to create
user friendly reports that can
be generated automatically,
for example, with
RStudio Connect.
So how can you use
data validation package
introduction?
Here's the example workflow.
So you can run the RStudio Connect
Scheduler daily.
And the scheduler can source
the data from a database
and validate the results. Based
on the validation results
a new data validator
report is created.
And we have two scenarios here.
So the validation fails.
In that case, a
report can be sent
to responsible stakeholders.
So a responsible
person can actually
take action and fix things.
And obviously, on
the other hand,
we also have all the scenarios.
So everything is great.
So the Shiny app can be
refreshed with the new data.
And the next step that
I'm going to cover
is testing, so the
face when you are actually
testing the whole
components in your app
and luckily, we have the shiny
test package from RStudio.
And that it's easy to
use for developers.
You can record the scenarios.
And this provides a quick
and simple way to test your Shiny apps.
On the other hand,
for more complex apps.
We recommend using Cypress,
but please be aware that this
requires knowledge of a little JavaScript.
But it's really,
really powerful.
And we reached the point that
your application actually
is ready to go live, so you
want to make sure that is
able to handle the traffic.
So here
you can use the shiny load
test package that enables
you to load test your deployed apps.
You can estimate how many
users your app can support,
you can identify
bottlenecks, and you
can use the test output to
guide you through the changes
if if the optimization
is actually necessary.
OK, and the last bit that you
really have to think about:
so you also want to make sure
that what you're actually
building is useful
for your users.
So please talk
to them and you
don't need to have a big budget
to do that because you can
always use the Hallway Test.
And the idea here
is that you can
show the application to your
colleagues or to end users
and let them click
through it and they
can describe what they
are doing and what
they understand is happening.
And recent studies show that if
you do it to five people,
you will learn around 85%
of the usability problems.
And obviously, if you
don't do it at all,
you will learn zero problems.
So the things I want
you to take home: organize
your code with Shiny modules,
R6 classes, or modules,
depending on the app
complexity you see
to run the length
and tests, you have
to use renv control your dependencies,
and automate code testing
and validations.
Thank you very much.